what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and what a finale Loki season 2 episode
6 the final episode of the season was
truly amazing go ahead and let me know
what you thought about it in the
comments down below and rate it one out
of 10 we're going to do a lot of videos
talking about the finale for Loki season
2 but in this specific video we are
going to go over exactly what Loki did
in the finale and I'll do my best to
explain it in the most simplistic way
possible so if you're wondering what
exactly happened or if you have friends
who are wondering watch this video and
send this to them also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel so you can
check out our other Loki videos and our
upcoming Marvel videos we're also giving
away a PS5 and Xbox series X all you got
to do to enter the giveaway is subscribe
to the channel and leave a comment down
below so again we'll do other videos
breaking down a lot of what happened in
the finale but specifically we'll talk
about Loki really becoming the life of
the Multiverse in in the finale so Loki
controls his time slipping and he goes
back to the point to where Victor timley
is about to go out to the time Loom
where he dies and the time Loom explodes
and is about to destroy the TVA after
literal centuries of learning physics
The Man spent hundreds of years learning
physics to try and understand everything
that OB knew he realized ultimately that
they could not prevent the time Loom
from exploding so Loki realized what he
had to do he had to go back in time
before he killed he who remains and he
tries to explain sylv you cannot kill
him if you kill him everything gets
destroyed because at this point Loki
believes that when the time Loom
explodes it destroys basically the
entire Multiverse and of course the TVA
so Loki is kind of realized at this
point he who remains cannot die so he's
doing everything he can to stop Sylvie
from killing him because when he who
remains dies the timeline starts to
Branch they won't prune the timeline
since he who remains isn't around
anymore to control the TVA the branches
will ultimately overload the time Loom
which will cause it to explode
destroying the entire Multiverse and
this is where we start to get presented
with Loki's options one is he can let
Sylvie kill he who remains and basically
end up where he is now with the time
Loom being destroyed exploding and
killing the TVA and all of the people
that he cares about or he can kill
Sylvie she tells him this over and over
and over again as she continuously kills
he who remains and Loki Time Slips back
trying different ways to stop her each
time but old always fail so ultimately
he goes to he who remains out of
frustration and says why do you never
try to stop her fight back do something
so he who remains stops time for Sylvie
at least and he says how many times have
you been at this knowing exactly what is
going on Loki is time slipping trying to
stop her from killing him and he keeps
failing and Loki says what did you do
and he who remains says come on you're
telling me you haven't learned how to
pause time yet I thought you'd be way
past that and then Loki says how do you
know how did you know about me time slip
because to he who remains and where
they're at in time it should not have
happened yet but keep in mind this is
outside of space and time and in Loki in
season 2 we have seen things happen in
the past present and future all at the
exact same time simultaneously that's
what's happening here and he who remains
says who do you think paved that road
meaning this was all part of he who
remains his planned Loki time slipping
everything that he's been through Victor
timely everything was a part of he who
remains his plan he paved that road he
sent Loki down that path for a very
specific reason and he even confirms
this he says kiddo do you really think I
was just going to sit back and let her
kill me and that be it the end of he who
remains no like I told you reincarnation
and what he's speaking about here is
what I mentioned before the past him
dying but the present Loki showing up
right before he died is actually
happening at the same time basically he
who remains knew that when he died by
the the hands of Sylvie Loki would
eventually go back in time and stop her
from killing him therefore he never
really actually died even though he did
but he didn't Loki changed him dying he
undid it with him time slipping but he
who remains planned the entire thing so
he was conscious of everything now
ultimately Loki goes on to tell him this
is not the first time we've had this
conversation showing him that he knows
how to pause time and this is basically
where Loki gets presented with his
options and this is extremely important
he who remains explains what the time
Loom actually is he explains that it's a
fail safe and when it gets overloaded
with too many branches it deletes the
ones that aren't supposed to be there
basically it only leaves the sacred
timeline and it does this by essentially
exploding like we've seen it do and when
it does this it'll kill the TVA and
everybody inside of it so then the
sacred timeline will be left but there
will be no TVA to prune the new branches
that come from it which will lead to a
multiversal war now Loki tries to argue
against him and combat him trying to
make up his own way stating well I'll
just let the sacred timeline branch and
I'll find all the variants myself and
kill them but he who remains explains
you can't there's too many there's an
infinite amount it won't matter if you
look for them but Loki says I'll break
the equation I will break the loom but
he who remains explains well if you do
that then your friends are going to die
so Loki decides he can't do that because
he can't live with his friends dying
Sylvie Mobius Casey Hunter B15 and
everybody else the thous thousands and
thousands and thousands of people at the
TVA because it is huge we've seen it
we've seen the city they'll all die and
from there they won't be able to monitor
any versions of King the Conqueror there
won't really be anybody to hunt down
King so this is where Loki kind of
understands what he who remains is
saying he's saying that Loki has two
choices he either kills Sylvie to
prevent her from killing he who remains
that option gives him this he who
remains stays in charge he monitors the
sacred timeline continues to prune
branches and the multiversal war never
happens and everything doesn't get
destroyed so that's option one option
two is to basically allow what happened
in the finale of Loki season 1 to play
out which would bring Loki to where he
was where the time Loom exploded it
would kill the TVA and everybody in it
all of his friends and then ultimately
the sacred timeline would Branch out
again and a multiversal war would happen
and everything would be destroyed and
there would be no TVA there to prevent
it so his two choices are let Sylvie
kill Ken and all of his friends will die
and the multiversal war will happen and
everything will get destroyed because
the TVA and nobody else will be there to
combat the Kang variant or kill Sylvie
the woman he loves also who is himself
let's not forget that and I love that
fact so basically Loki understands these
are his choices there's nothing else
that he can do that is until he talks to
Mobius and Sylvie now Mobius he goes to
talk to basically about how do you
choose he wants help from his friend he
basically has to choose between the
distru uction of the Multiverse and
everybody he loves or the one person
that he loves the most and it's only by
speaking to Sylvie the person that he
loves the most that gets him to
understand something that he actually
could do a third option Sylvie says do
you really want to be the god that takes
away Everybody's Free Will that's the
option of killing Sylvie and allowing he
who remains to continue to prune every
timeline except for the sacred timeline
offering no free will to anyone ever
everything is predetermined and written
by he who remains but Loki says but what
good is Free Will if everyone's dead and
here's where Sylvie Sparks a new idea in
Loki's head she says who are you to
decide we can't die fighting then she
says you're
replacing one nightmare with another and
you can see in the scene Loki gets a
spark of an idea he realizes what he can
now do Loki then says if there's a hope
that you can replace that thing with
something better the key word here is
replace then Loki goes back in time to
right before the time loan explodes
right before victor goes out and dies
and Loki says I know what I want I know
what kind of God I need to be then he
goes out and he himself destroys the
time Loom it doesn't activate the fail
safe it doesn't explode causing a huge
explosion that would kill the TVA and
everybody inside of it but he takes it
down himself and he knows what he's
doing he's doing it for a very specific
purpose after he takes out the time Loom
he sees that all of the timelines all
the branch
are dying and this is an extremely
important part notice he grabs one
timeline at first enchants it gives it
life but when he lets go it dies so this
is really important Loki has to
continuously be giving life to these
branches to these timelines or they will
die literally the entire Multiverse will
die unless Loki gives them life and Loki
knows this he knows that this is what he
has to do he is essentially replacing
the time Loop he is replacing he who
remains he was presented with two
options but he chose his own path his
own way which is who Loki really and
truly is so now Loki having spent
centuries time slipping and learning
more about time can now control time so
what does he do he cuts a hole in space
and time and it looks like he goes back
to where the void was to where the
Citadel at the end of time was where he
who remains was and he takes the
timelines there so he is right now
existing outside of space and time and
he takes the Multiverse with him and he
essentially becomes the power source the
life of the entire Multiverse without
him there are no timelines there are no
universes there's nothing without Loki
now Loki is literally the life of the
Multiverse so he sits on his throne and
he becomes igil which in Norse mythology
is a large tree of life that connects
the nine Realms of existence and it sort
sort of a cosmic access that binds all
of existence together and it represents
the inner connectivity of everything in
existence we actually saw idrasil in the
very first Thor movie and Thor explains
to Jane that her world is one of nine
Realms of the cosmos linked to each
other by the branches of igdrasil the
world's tree so Loki is now essentially
igdrasil he is everything that holds the
interconnectivity of the entire
Multiverse of the entire existence
together and Loki did did this so his
friends could live and so everybody in
every Universe could have free will no
Kang variant controlling time writing
time but the TVA does exist but they
exist for a new reason now we saw this
at the end they solely exist to hunt
down problematic Kang variants so they
are no longer pruning timelines they are
letting the Multiverse exist they are
giving people their Free Will except for
Nathaniel richards's evil King variance
so essentially they are trying to stop
the multiversal war and they believe
that this will work unfortunately we
know Secret Wars is coming and we know
that the Council of kings are already
here along with thousands of other king
variants and really Advanced variants of
King the Conqueror not like Victor
timley but ones born in the 31st Century
can figure out how to exist outside of
space and time so they can avoid being
in any universe but they can exist
outside of a universe which the TVA
can't detect and Loki probably can't
detect either because we see at the end
that Loki can monit
the Multiverse he heard Mobius say let
time pass by and he smiled because he
heard it he observed it he can observe
probably every single universe but he
can't leave because he holds it all
together so now Loki is essentially the
Multiverse he's literally holding it all
together and giving it life it can't
exist without him now he is idrasil he
is the Tree of Life Giving life to every
universe so he is the savior of the
Multiverse that is his glorious purpose
which by the way episode 1 of Loki
season 1 is called glorious purpose and
this episode the finale of Loki season 2
is also called glorious purpose so that
is also an Orab borus a snake eating its
own tail a Time Loop which could signify
the end of the Loki series and if this
is the end what a phenomenal end
although I do believe we'll probably see
Loki in Avengers Secret Wars again but
go ahead and let me know your thoughts
about this I hope this video helped
again you have to understand what
happened during the episode Loki
presented with the two choices him
taking his own path he saved his friends
he saved the TVA he saved the Multiverse
he who remains is now dead the TVA are
hunting down Kang variants and Loki is
holding the entire Multiverse together
and giving it life let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below don't forget to subscribe and hit
that notification Bell to be alerted
when we do our other Loki videos and of
course other Marvel videos you can find
us on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof